notre histoire c'est celle d'un grand
parti de droite qui a donné à la france
ses institutions avec et autour du
général de gaulle moi je suis fier fier
d'être d'une famille politique qui a
fait voter 2 grande loi sur le handicap
celle de 75 et celle de 2005
fier d'être d'une famille politique qui
a tant fait pour le droit des femmes liv
et j'ai avec simone veil et jacques
chirac c'est nous et personne d'autre
fier d'être dans une famille politique
qui a toujours depuis 1945 défendu la
politique familiale que françois
hollande puis emmanuel macron ont
détricoté si les français avaient voulu
que nous disparaissions ne serions plus
là il n'imagine pas en réalité au plus
profond d'eux-mêmes que la vie politique
française puisse se structurer sans un
grand mouvement de droite capable
d'assurer l'alternance un grand parti de
gouvernement qui puisse demain reprendre
en main le destin de notre pays le temps
de la récolte viendra est ce un paysan
qui vole vite car nous avons en nous
cette cohérence idéologique
rebâtir donner à nouveau aux français à
l'échelle nationale l' envie de nous
écouter l' envie de nous respecter de
nous suivre il faut travailler notre
projet avec conviction avec humilité
avec sang froid c'est ce travail qui est
en cours et c'est autour de ce travail
que nous devons rester mobilisés
un travail qui s'appuie sur un socle de
valeurs la liberté
l'autorité le progrès est sur un
héritage profond dans l'histoire de
notre pays
[Musique]